[Music]
[Laughter]
my brothers don't eat crumpets
today man is here doing reactions which
is
lv's track of the week today i'm going
to be reviewing yom baines
nate smalls and m huntro the tunes
called dancing on ice
make sure you've got like subscribe
share to the channel no further no do
is it no further no do well i don't know
because when i said it last time man was
laughing about no further no do
and i thought yeah it does sound a bit
mad but anyway let's just get on with
the show
[Music]
i love when they write the writing on
the screen because like everyone just
could speak to it you know
like see sometimes when you're listening
to tracks you can't you don't know the
words do you but when the words are
there
it all just comes to mind easy she just
text me
[Applause]
[Music]
when so you obviously know nate's doing
his things
the boss of melodies that whole
situation
yeah man revealed man but obviously some
people you know i've you know i've
noticed in this
in this whole like industry itself like
people in general yeah
if a man's doing well yeah and like the
minute you can try and
find a bad point or something negative
about them and then it's like it wants
to blow up and make it a big thing or oh
we've seen his face look oh now we're
going to mock him and uh
louder brother man that's why he hid his
face in the first place he probably
didn't want no one to know who he is
because he didn't want to go through the
grief
but what i would say is blood carry on
doing what you're doing fam wear your
mask if you want to
don't wear your mask so if you don't
want you do you get me
[Music]
she dance text me calm can't keep still
see this tune it's got such a vibe to it
it's like
you just you ever do obviously i've got
to do my shoulders because i
i'm in a chair i would be dancing and
all over the place i can't do that here
today because it's not that holding down
homework
[Music]
the other one's taking smoke every
smokiness cliff
or he's burning us
[Applause]
[Music]
on some drive fighting come on get out
of there
yeah beat that up time every time in my
back cause my own slime
[__] the hoe in my chat
i don't even
[Music]
i know
come she just texts me
come so the girl wants men to come
around how did they spell come
on see you in bro come
busting up
[Music]
beam that tuned there was a mazzar
yeah young banes nave smalls
m huncho dancing on ice you get me
i'm gonna rate that that's definitely
your eight and a half nine
like the reason why i went to ten i i
probably weren't focusing so much on the
vid like that but there weren't enough
gyan
i wanted to see some beauties and girls
shaking and
you know and i had a thing set already
man i hope you guys enjoyed the show
i've been your player lv general
lumpet slumpit my brothers don't eat
crumpets over
and out